welcome to this video playing jammie
Dodger from the UK and I've played
against him a number of times and he's
got a new line he lost tons of games in
the in the what is again em in the pan
off the panel and now he's going for the
fantasy variation and I have this sharp
line that I am that I play and again
forgot how to play should see five takes
Bishop c5 but he doesn't take funny hmm
ok let's take them what now maybe Knight
f6 this looks very much like a Bronstein
Lauzon ok I won't just find the right
moves anyway so be quick about it
of course the structure looks bad for
both players f three years a ridiculous
move here in the structure you never
would play that if you if you would have
the option have it back on f 2 you would
would have it back on f 2 but black has
got this double bond formation with the
five I only went for that because
there's f3 plate means that his
development is a bit cluttered up the
Queen only six is always looking at the
beach hoop answer yep he needs to do
something to to get his Queen side
developed maybe he's intended Quincy to
Bishop e3 something like that should be
three hmm is there some way to to
counter that or should I just you know I
should just probably develop
it is hanging so he doesn't the Saudi
five isn't a move
yeah this is some what I expected and I
thought maybe I can just take it take
and try to use my my good development
yeah I do that I'm really better
developed and he cannot castle short
really I mean after takes Knight eggs he
we cannot castle short because I won't
be six Andrew p8 so yeah I thought this
wasn't possible as well because of
Bishop a two why isn't this working
ok
we should be three why not we should be
396 or is this the point i 96 seconds of
steak should see 595 maybe 95 okay maybe
I should just just take first this is
easier and now just move the night 95
maybe
come on first this mission this also
introduces the idea of Queen a 585 to a
one which isn't isn't a small threat
that's really something that watch needs
to be a careful about Queen a one mate
so he ok now 95 was my intention this
looks nice
just active
and I'm not behind on the clock for once
hmm so just take it I can maybe take
with the pawn mmm I don't want that
really this isn't too bad where does he
go
yes but Queen a one isn't Queen a 1 a
good move first taking right Jake this
first Queen a one attacking beaten with
meet another check he's got this check
hmm
let's just prevent 96 and threaten queen
a one
hmm he's just planning night if Wow I
know don't tell me this is good for
white Bishop f5 and this Bishop is
hanging if I'm losing this I'm going to
cry I mean really cannot believe that of
course of course Bishop f5 has says it's
a pen it's a pen oh wow this was a
really really bad moment I thought
Bishop f5 and I'm busted but I'm pinning
this opening the bishop who I overlooked
this completely just lucky that I'm not
not lost on or something okay but what
is he going to do maybe place 93
I'm not sure what my responses to that
Bishop Bishop a 2-1 prolly yeah come on
check Queen a form check
wow this looks good controls squares and
intense night b5 check
yeah maybe I should have played for from
medium but what can you do okay is not
not secured not too quick so I actually
managed to check win this acquisition
time morning check check check just take
it check check me whoo yeah I overlooked
a couple of things here and there was
lucky that it didn't cost me Wow when he
played 95 this was a bad moment so here
I really thought oh my Bishop f5 and I'm
busted but the Queen a oneness is
winning and in fact the computer are the
computer 93 okay now look at this this
is the best move this is nice just nice
winning on b1 oops tent if it takes
check making to meet very nice yeah this
is the way it should be played not any
end game or something just mate you know
okay but an entertaining game I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching